>> Reporter: WE BEGIN WITH BRAND
NEW CNN REPORTING ON THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION.
SOURCES TELLING CNN DONALD
TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS ARE WAGING A
SECRET COURT FIGHT TO STOP A
GRAND JURY FROM GATHERING
INFORMATION FROM MR. TRUMP'S
INNER CIRCLE.
THE FIGHT BROKE INTO PUBLIC VIEW
YESTERDAY AND CNN TEAMS -- THREE
LAWYERS FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AT THE FEDERAL COURTHOUSE HERE
IN WASHINGTON.
THE BACK-AND-FORTH BATTLE
FOLLOWS A DELUGE OF NEW
SUBPOENAS FROM FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS DEMANDING EVIDENCE
FROM A SLEW OF FORMER TRUMP
AIDES AND ASSOCIATES.
LET'S BRING IN CNN'S SENIOR
JUSTICE CORRESPONDENT EVAN PEREZ
AND CNN'S CRIME AND JUSTICE
REPORTER.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU HERE.
HOW DOES THIS WORK?
EXPLAIN THE DETAILS HERE AND WHY
THEY MATTER.
>> RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN SECRECY OR
THIS PROCEEDING IS VEILED IN
SECRECY BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT IS
ONGOING, A GRAND JURY PROCEEDING
WHERE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
TRYING TO GET INFORMATION INTO
THE GRAND JURY INCLUDING AROUND
DONALD TRUMP AROUND THE WHITE
HOUSE POTENTIALLY EVEN FROM
ATTORNEYS OF HIS AND AT THIS
TURNING POINT RIGHT NOW THE
TRUMP LAWYERS, THESE THREE MEN
WE DID SEE EXITING THE FEDERAL
COURT YESTERDAY, THEY'RE
REPRESENTING DONALD TRUMP.
THEY'RE OPPOSITE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
IN COURT BEFORE A JUDGE THEY
WOULD BE ARGUING THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO KEEP INFORMATION OUT
OF THE GRAND JURY'S HANDS, KEEP
WITNESSES FROM TURNING OVER OR
TESTIFYING ABOUT INFORMATION,
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO
ASSERT VARIOUS PRIVILEGES THAT
COULD INCLUDE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AS WELL AS ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
THE JUDGE WOULD ULTIMATELY HAVE
TO DECIDE.
HUGE IMPLICATIONS AND REALLY A
STEP FORWARD FOR BOTH THE TRUMP
TEAM AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> EVAN, LOOK, I FEEL LIKE I
ASKED YOU BOTH ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE WEEK, CAN YOU TOP LINE
THIS FOR ME?
CAN YOU EXPLAIN?
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
MOVING PARTS.
IT IS SUCH A FLUID SITUATION.
WHEN YOU REPORT ON THIS, WHEN
YOU TALK TO SOURCES ABOUT THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE, WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN BIG PICTURE FOR HOW THINGS
ARE PROGRESSING?
>> THE BIG PICTURE HERE IS THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE STEP THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN TO GET
THROUGH THIS FIRE WALL THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TRYING
TO BUILD AND SOURCES HAVE TOLD
US THAT THIS FIGHT, YOU KNOW,
THEY'VE BEEN GIRDING FOR THIS.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
GIRDING FOR THE POSSIBILITY THAT
ONCE THEY BRING IN WITNESSES,
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT WITNESSES,
LIKE THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL, PAT CIPOLLONE, HIS
DEPUTY, PAT PHILBIN, THAT
THEY'LL HAVE TO GO BACK AND ASK
QUESTIONS THAT WOULD GET THROUGH
THAT PRIVILEGE CLAIM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS MAKING.
AND SO NOW THAT HAS BEGUN.
>> ONE SPECIFIC WITNESS THAT I
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT, WE KNOW
THAT ERIC HERSHMAN A FORMER
WHITE HOUSE ATTORNEY, I BELIEVE,
WAS SCHEDULED TO GIVE TESTIMONY
ON SEPTEMBER 2nd.
WHAT IS THE LATEST WITH THAT?
>> HIS TESTIMONY WAS DELAYED.
AT LEAST SOME OF THIS FIGHT
APPEARS TO BE CENTERED AROUND
HIM AND SOME OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES WHO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN THESE VAGUE
INSTRUCTIONS, BROAD CLAIMS OF
PRIVILEGE, WHICH HAS CAUSED THIS
FIGHT TO EVOLVE.
AND SO HOW THIS WORKS OUT WILL
BE A HUGE, HUGE THING FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO GET THIS
INFORMATION IS KEY TO BEFORE
THEY MAKE A DECISION ON WHO GETS
CHARGED, WHETHER IT'S THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HIMSELF, OR SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AROUND HIM
WHO ARE TRYING TO OVERTURN THE
2020 ELECTION.
>> AS OUR RESIDENT LEGAL WHIZ ON
ALL THE THINGS, THE PRIVILEGE
CLAIM JUST GENERALLY RIGHT NOW,
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF QUESTIONS
IN LEGAL CIRCLES ABOUT HOW MUCH
VALIDITY IT ACTUALLY HAS.
WHEN YOU TALK TO PEOPLE PAYING
CLOSE ATTENTION TO THIS, WHAT IS
THEIR SENSE OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM EITHER IN
THIS CASE SPECIFICALLY OR MORE
BROADLY ACTUALLY HAS RATIONAL
BACKING FOR WHAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO ARGUE?
>> THESE ARE VERY SERIOUS ISSUES
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE RAISING
HERE, EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THERE IS A LOT THAT HAS NOT BEEN
SETTLED IN THAT AREA.
WE ARE IN UNCHARTED TERRITORY AS
WE FIND OURSELVES WITH DONALD
TRUMP OCCASIONALLY IN COURT.
IN THIS SORT OF THING, IF
HISTORY IS ANY GUIDE, IF LEGAL
PRECEDENT IS ANY GUIDE, IF THERE
ARE ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGES,
CONFIDENTIALITY BETWEEN THE
ATTORNEY TALKING TO A CLIENT,
THE CLIENT WOULD BE DONALD
TRUMP, THOSE OFTEN FALL AWAY
VERY QUICKLY IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
THE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS A
LITTLE HARDER TO GET PAST FOR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATORS BUT
RICHARD NIXON WAS TRYING TO
ASSERT THESE SORTS OF THINGS.
THE SUPREME COURT HAD RULINGS ON
THAT THAT ULTIMATELY LED TO HIS
DEPARTURE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> EVAN, DO WE KNOW WHAT
PROSECUTORS WANT TO USE THIS
INFO FOR?
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY A TON WE
CAN'T SEE.
THAT'S BEEN MADE VERY CLEAR OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS WITH ALL
THE SUBPOENAS.
WHAT IS THE INTENT HERE?
WHAT ARE THEY GOING FOR?
>> WE KNOW FROM OUR OWN
REPORTING AND SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'VE SEEN IN PUBLIC THERE ARE
SOME TARGETS THAT, CLEARLY, ARE
IN SIGHT.
THAT INCLUDES JEFFREY CLARK,
JOHN EASTMAN, PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO STOP DONALD TRUMP FROM
LEAVING OFFICE AND TO KEEP HIM
IN POWER DESPITE THE FACT HE
LOST THE ELECTION.
SO THOSE TWO ARE ABSOLUTELY MORE
LIKELY TO BE FACING CHARGES AT
SOME POINT.
BEYOND THAT, THERE ARE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO THE PROSECUTORS
CLEARLY HAVE A DEEP INTEREST IN.
RUDY GUILIANI IS ONE OF THEM.
THERE ARE ALL THOSE PEOPLE
TRYING TO SET UP THE FAKE
ELECTOR SCHEME, RIGHT?
AND OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY THE ONE WHO WAS
HELPING TO GUIDE ALL OF THIS AND
IT IS NOT CLEAR WHETHER
PROSECUTORS CAN GET THERE BUT
THIS IS PART OF WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO.
>> WE KNOW THERE ARE WITNESSES
THAT WERE INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT HAVE BEEN CALLED TO THE
GRAND JURY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE.
>> SO MANY DIFFERENT ELEMENTS.
YOU GUYS ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
REPORTING ON ALL OF IT AND
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS WHEN I
CALL YOU RANDOMLY LIKE AT 6:00
IN THE MORNING.
THANKS, GUYS, SO MUCH.